Trascrizione: Valentina Franzoni
Revisore: Inés Galiano Torres
Buongiorno a tutti
Be', pensavo di essere emozionato
e invece è molto peggio
Vabe',
Io mi trovo in uno di quei momenti
dove la vita ti chiede di fare
un bilancio, no? Capire dove sei,
come sei, a volte anche perche sei cosí
e io sono in uno di questi momenti
perché quest'anno
ho raggiunto i quarant'anni
"non li dimostri, li porti benissimo"... grazie!
e a quaranta anni
grazie a un algoritmo
ho scoperto diciamo una formula matematica
che è il motivo per cui mi hanno chiamato
qui al TEDx
che a quaranta anni non hai piu vent'anni
capisco la vostra invidia nella mia preparazione
e quindi ho analizato un po' chi ero e cosa facevo
a vent'anni
e mi sono accorto, analizando un po le scelte
che ho fatto quando avevo vent'anni
che, non so se vi è sucesso anche a voi,
ma le prime scelte, le prime decisioni che facevo
oh, a me andavano tutte dritte.
Ah, verso i quindici anni ho fatto
un concorso per DJ, ho vinto, ho cominciato a far la carriera del DJ, ho cominciato
a girare il mondo, a 18 ho fatto un disco, m'è andato anche questo disco
e ho cominciato, mia mamma contentissima,
maestra delle Elementari, vedere suo figlio che fa il DJ era proprio una soddisfazione
veramente forte, però, le cose mi stavano andando bene
le cose mi stavano andando bene e a un certo punto, ovviamente,
ho iniziato la mia carriera di errori, ovviamente, c'è, non è che,
questo è normale
però quando cominci a fare degli errori ti arriva sempre una mano sulla spalla
abbastanza brutta, senza corpo, proprio,
ti arriva una mano, e ti dice, vai tranquillo Stefano, ricordati che sbagliando si impara
e io con questa frase qui, insomma, l'ho sentita dire con questa mano terrificante,
ho visto troppi walking dead. Comunque c'è questa mano
che mi tocca la spalla e mi dice, vai tranquillo Stefano, che
sbagliando si impara.
Con questa frase io mi sono accorto che ho iniziato nella mia vita
a concentrarmi, ogni volta che dovevo fare una scelta, mi concentravo
di piu, sull come non sbagliare, invece di concentrarmi sul come fare le cose
esatte, che sembra la stessa cosa, ma non è proprio la stessa cosa e infatti io
reputo e mi sono ricavato questa mia filosofia di vita, che sbagliando si sbaglia,
e ne sono anche molto convinto, perché è vero che se io da un errore
posso capire come fare la volta sucessiva una decisione corretta
è vero, se ci fosse la casualità, che non ci sia una decisione uguale a un'altra,
ma è impossibile, perché qualsiasi decisione nasce in contesto diverso, ha un ambiente diverso,
non potrà mai essere uguale a quella precedente, anzi, vi posso dire una cosa,
per me, ogni volta che sbaglio è un pugno nella pancia,
mi mette un po' piu di tempo per fare la decisione succesiva
e quindi sono entrato un po in crisi, perché ho detto, ma ,
se accumulare sperienza, potrebbe essere una delle caratteristiche che mi fa
sbagliare di più, sono andato un po,
un po in crisi, vi dico la verità.
Però, cosa è suceso, che un giorno la mia vita è cambiata
e ho avuto la fortuna che la mia vita è cambiata in uno scenario
da vero bello , di quelli che ti ricordi, in Auto Grill,
che è un posto meraviglioso dove ti deve cambiare la vita, perché in Auto Grill, non so
se vi è mai suceso, ma io mi fermo in quel reparto, assolutamente vicino agli occhiali di sole in plastica,
ci sono i libri di marketing, fantastici, come fare google in sette giorni,
se non hai un gareggio non puoi fare una estratta, tutti questi libri che io compro, tutti,
ovviamente, e in uno di questi libri, però, lessi una frase che
a me, davvero cambio la vita, che fu,
Per Avere qualcosa che non hai mai avuto,
devi fare qualcosa che non hai mai fatto.
Io ero con i miei cannoli, perché era suceso un po di tempo fa, facevo un po di cannoli,
e lessi questa frase e per me fu davvero un raggio di luce e decisi di applicare subito questa
che per me era la mia formula nuova di vita, ho detto,
provo subito a sconfingere
quella che era la mia nemica di sempre,
la mia nemica storica, per me, la mia nemica storica
è la rutina. per anni io mi sono infilato, in questa lotta per cercare di
vincere la routine. A volte si riuscivo, ma poi ci ricadevo e allora ho detto, aspetta,
provo a fare una cosa diversa, provo a pensarla diversamente, perche quando vuoi uscire dalla rutina,
non so come mai, penso sempre al macro, allora cambio lavoro,
vado all'estero, cerco sempre di fare un qualcosa, una bomba nella mia vita,
ho detto, proviamo invece a cambiare le piccole cose,
ho detto, provo, a trasformarmi la mia rutina in una rutina meraviogliosa , c'è non solo
non ci ho più come nemica, ma diventa la mia migliore amica, ho detto,
sai cosa faccio, io provo a diventare un errore del quotidiano
e sono partito con delle stupidaggine apocalittiche, del tipo, ho fatto una settimana,
ho fatto gli oscar della brioche, perche ho detto se la brioche è un elemento che si deve inserire in tutti giorni
della mia vita, c'è, non è che posso dare questo acceso a la prima brioche che capita,
ho fatto una settimana a testare tutti i bar vicino al mio studio
poi ho fatto le presentazioni col video e tutto, ha vinto la brioche del cioccolato del bar Italia,
e quello è diventato il mio bar
ho applicato questo modo di non dare lo scontato e
cambiare le micro cose, nelle telefonate, nel raporto con le persone, quant'altro, e
ho cominciato a vedere davvero del miglioramento, fino a che
è suceso un po di tempo fa, su questa scia, ho detto, faccio una cosa che facevo quindici anni fa,
ho vero provo ad andare ad un appuntamento in provincia di Milano
sembra quasi veramente un test di quelli tosti, in provincia di Milano,
ma senza il navigatore.
Ho fatto una giornata vinta, provo senza il navigatore
ovviamente, io veramente c'ho il senso dell'orientamento di una lucerna
quindi ho detto, parto un'ora prima, non so perché m'è venuta,
però , parto un'ora prima, ho detto,
e non vi nascondo, che sono andato in dubbio sul'esperimento che avevo fatto perché
non solo arrivai tranquillamente a destinazione, ma c'hai arrivai anche un quarto d'ora in anticipo
e quindi non capivo questo
questo rapporto che stavo cercando tra obiettivo e percorso,
poi invece analizzando cosa m'era suceso, capì la grossissima differenza di quello che avevo fatto,
il fatto che non avessi utilizzato il navigatore, mi costrinse a fare un percorso dove ero
altamente stressato, dove non riuscivo a tenere il volume della radio alto, perché, come se il volume non mi facesse vedere le
strade, era una sensazione strannissima, non rispondevo al telefono
perché ogni volta che suonava il telefono, ffh,
ero cattivo come una bestia, e quando sono arrivato al appuntamento ho stretto la mano e la
prima cosa che gli ho detto, posso andare in bagno?
e quindi ho capito che cosa mi serviva il navigatore, a arrivare puntuale? no
mi serviva per raggiungere il percorso? no
il navigatore, l'obiettivo finale, mi doveva servire per crearmi
un bellissimo percorso, non può essere il percorso al servizio del obiettivo ma per me personalmente,
è il contrario, è il contrario,
perche io penso che senza un percorso meraviglioso, l'obbiettivo, è mancato , anche se l'ho raggiunto
e quindi l'obbiettivo finale dev'essere il primo punto del cercare di costruirmi un percorso
meraviglioso, perche mal che vada, anche se non raggiungo l'obbiettivo finale, comunque,
ho fatto un bel percorso,
c'è, mi sentivo, ho fatto un ragionamento, certo , veramente...
volevo fondare io il TED, ho detto, guarda che il ragionamento che ho fatto,
ok, ma però ho detto ,porca miseria, non c'ho più vent'anni, ho detto, pensa, se avessi fatto questo raggionamento
quando ci avevi vent'anni, ho detto no, quante scelte, quanti percorsi, avrei fatto in modo diverso
quando vedo i ragazzi cosí ho detto, mado, dovete capirla sta cosa, fate qualcosa, ok,
pero ho avuto una fortuna,
che mi sono trovato, a fare questo tipo di chiacherata, con una persona che aveva più del doppio
della mia età,e ovviamente
l'argomento è stato il tempo
io gli ho spiegato tutta la mia arringa e lui mi fa
Stefano, ma, tu, quanti anni hai?
e ho detto, ah non mi hai ascoltato, e mi fa, quanti anni hai?
e io gli faccio, quaranta, e quanti soldi hai? gli ho detto, sì
quanti soldi hai? cincuanta euro, e mi fa, no, non hai capito la domanda
quanti anni hai? quaranta, e quanti soldi hai? e gli ho detto cinquanta euro. No, Stefano, quanti...
ma, ti do un cartone, e vieni al dunque, gli ho detto, perché, e mi fa
ma scusa, Stefano, io non ho capito una cosa, stiamo parlando di ricchezza, no? il tempo è
il denaro, sono richeze, non è proprio... ma non ho capito una cosa, ma perché quanto ti chiedo quanti soldi hai
mi dici quelli che hai e quando ti chiedo quanti anni hai mi dici quelli che non hai più?
i ho ci ho messo un sei sette minuti per capire, poi, però,
quando ho capito ho detto, pazzesco, è vero,
c'è, la mia richezza, sono i soldi che ancora ho, che posso ancora avere per fare delle cose che non ho mai fatto
ma è lo stesso con il tempo, era pazzesco, io mi trovavo a quarant'anni che avevo vent'anni,
non solo, avevo un sacco di vent'anni, e bello di quando hai un sacco di volte vent'anni
non è la quantità di scelte che puoi ancora fare, ma è il fatto che tutte le scelte che devo ancora fare
sono bellissime, per una caratteristica che unisce, che non gli ho mai sbagliate
perche le devo ancora fare, allora gli ho detto, pazzesco
ma se il tempo quindi viene gestito da questi errori di quotidiano,
dove cominciano, a cambiare e a fare delle cose diverse nel micro, nelle piccole cose,
con questo tipo di visione, ho detto cosa potrebbe succedere?
potrebbe succedere che riusciamo a sconfigere quello che secondo me
è uno dei mali più grossi, quanto meno che a me afligge, ma lo vedo veramente,
che a quella situazione dove capisci il valore della cose solo quando le perdi
io questa legge non la sopporto, io non posso capire il valore di una amicizia quando la perdo
non posso capire il valore di stare un weekend con i miei genitori quando non potrò più fare questa cosa
non posso accettare questo tipo di malatia, e non solo , io non mi acontento di capire quand'è il momento in cui
sta sucedendo, che è già un bon paso, io mi sto accorgendo,
che sto vivendo un momento che poi racconterò, quello è già un buon punto, ma quello che io
vorrei fare, quello che vorrei fare, è eliminare il fattore casualità dall'equazione della felicità
perché se io penso in questo modo, arriverà a un punto dove me ne sto
rendendo conto che sto per fare uno di quei momenti che racconterò
io mi sto rendendo conto che sto per fare la mia storia
e quando farò la storia, quando riuscirò a fare quel momento sarà un momento bellissimo per tutte le
personne che mi sono state vicino, per tutte le persone che mi conoscono, anche
per le persone che non mi conoscono, ma,
quando tu sai che stai per entrare nella storia, ci sono, quarantotto secondi, prima di fare la storia,
che quelli sono tutti nostri. Grazie.